[Music]
good morning everybody my name is
Agustin Fontes and I am a product
manager on the Android UI framework team
and if you're wondering I do work on
Android text and fonts and yes font is
my real last name so with that out of
the way let's let's begin so today we we
want to cover a few things first we want
to convey how we think about apk size
and a couple of metrics that we think
you really should should care about for
the success of your app we'll also walk
through a series of best practices that
are going to help you reduce your apk
size today as well as show you a number
of new tools and features that we are
going to introduce this week that will
also help you keep your apk size down so
let's get started one of the things
you'll see today is that we have a
really diverse group of people from
Google people from the Android team from
the tools team from the Play team
internal developers at Google and the
reason we have so many people on stage
with different backgrounds is because we
really think that apk size is super
important and it's something that we see
as something you have to take care of
from the design stage the time you build
your app the time you publish your app
and the time that that app gets
delivered to a device so let me tell you
a little bit about kind of the two
dimensions that that we think are
important for apk size first is the
download size so this is the size of the
application when it's in the Play Store
and it gets delivered to the device this
is highly compressed and we'll tell you
more about how we how we do that and
that allows us to save a lot of size on
the wire and end-users data now as we
said download size is pretty small but
there's another another concept that's
important which is installed sighs so
installed size is what happens when you
actually download the app unpack it and
then compile it and optimize it which
expands the application significantly
yielding a download size that is
sometimes two to three times even bigger
than the download size and so it's
something to really think about is what
is the footprint of your application
going to be once it's installed on the
device now let's talk a little bit about
why you should care about both download
size and install size on the download
size for
this is something really important
because what happens is when a user goes
and installs an app they're going to see
that loading bar and they're going to
see the actual size of the application
and what we see is the larger the app
the more sort of user regret that
happens and a lot of people will go and
actually back out of it and cancel and
so what we see is that up to 20% of
downloads fail or get canceled rather
when applications are over 100 megabytes
and so you really want to keep that the
download size small to ensure that you
get as much distribution for your app as
possible the other one to think about is
installed size now install size has a
sort of a similar phenomenon right so
users are going to be filling up their
phones with photos videos more
applications and at some point they're
going to try to install a new app and
they're going to realize that they don't
have space for it what's going to happen
at that point is it going to go hunting
they're going to go to their settings
I'm going to look for their apps or if
they're Disqus full and they try to
download an app from the Play Store even
the Play Store will suggest that they
remove some applications and they give
them a list of suggestions what we see
here is that again apps that are pretty
large especially 100 megabytes or above
are eight times more likely to be
removed from the device so this is
really going to hurt your reengagement
if your app is more likely to get
uninstalled so I hope that I've given
you sort of like a little bit of
motivation to think twice maybe three
times about your apk size go back and
and think about what you can do and we
want to show you today is a number of
ways you can you can follow to reduce
that apk size some are going to be
existing practices that have been out
there for a while we're going to hope to
summarize and make them really compact
for you and others are new and we're
going to show you those so let's let's
roll up our sleeves we're going to be
working with the Topeka app you may have
seen it in our code labs or sample saps
ample sample apps Topeka is a quiz app
so it has a lot of a lot of resources a
lot of assets and it also has a good
chunk of Dex code this is what gets
compiled and expanded on device is
definitely a good opportunity to to
tackle Dex code and make it smaller to
do it's out size impact in a typical
production app you might also see some
shared objects this doesn't happen in
Topeka but we'll cover a little bit also
what you can do with your shared objects
so at this point I'd like to hand it
over to Shai who's going to run through
a lot of these concepts and best
practices in real time so hopefully you
see that it's not so difficult and it's
something you can do with your app
thanks mr. Phan so here we have our app
built and running I can press build apk
to get an apk and then press analyze apk
to crack it open and see what it's made
of I already have it open here so an apk
is just a glorified zip file here we can
see all this contents we can browse
through the resources folder to see all
the large drawables that really dominate
the most bytes in our app we can look at
classes.dex that stands for dalvik
executable and see all the code for our
app as well as of some of our
dependencies we can even look inside
resources out arsc and see for instance
all the translatable strings and styles
and dimensions and other resources that
are that end up in resources a RAC we
can even look at the Android manifest
binary XML and decode ad
notice that there are two columns with
size information first we have raw file
size this is how much every particular
item contributes to the size of the apk
as a file on disk the second is download
size which better represents how much
bytes the user will actually have to
download from play in order to install
your app for the first time now you'll
see for instance that for resources
these numbers aren't very far apart
because resources are dominated by large
pngs
we have four draw bows these don't
benefit from further compression whereas
for some other items entropy is
typically lower and so the gains from
compression are higher we're going to
show you a bunch of tricks you can use
for this particular app which we're
going to use right now on stage and
we're going to show you their impact on
the app size for your own app your
mileage may vary rather than memorizing
these
killer steps if there's one lesson that
you should take home from this talk it's
that optimizing your own app size begins
with sort of finding out what's in it
and tailoring to that all right so first
step we're going to take is to use
ProGuard ProGuard is enabled by default
for release built and it's a whole
program Java optimizer what it does is
basically three things
so one thing it does is it optimizes
your code in ways that don't change the
functionality but do change the
representation to make it more compact
for instance it might inline certain
methods to their call sites if it's
deemed to be more efficient in some
cases it is another thing it does is the
obfuscated names of types and methods
and fields where the original name
doesn't matter
so that long names are replaced with
short strings like a and B for
efficiency I know we all like to give
our Java classes long names and our
packages but this shouldn't get in the
way of efficiency and then lastly
there's dead code elimination now this
is the most important role of Kroger to
pay attention think of your program as a
graph of classes methods and fields of
notes right and calls or references as
edges so Android apps have well-known
entry points at activities services
broadcast receivers content providers
and optionally a custom application
class if these classes are in your app
manifest then the platform can call into
them so ProGuard mark Simmons live
because this code can execute at runtime
right pro-gard then propagates liveness
across the program via references so
it's basically a tree exploration sort
of algorithm and anything that is
reachable from those seeds is considered
live then whatever code remains the
complement to that is presumed dead and
will be deleted from your app unless you
specify otherwise this is important to
be aware of so let's look at the impact
of that here's what happens when we run
ProGuard on topeka you'll see that most
of the code is now completely gone so
for instance if I look at the
a support library here I see that it's
considerably smaller than it was before
we can also get these results using the
apk analyzer we can compare one apk with
another here we have numbers in raw apk
size and over in the charts on the sides
I have it as download size thought you'd
appreciate that so if you will look
closely inside the dex file you'll
you'll see what I just showed you that
most of the support library code is gone
and most of the rest is obfuscated right
so what is going on why is this
happening this is there we go why is
this happening
pro-gard allows you to choose what
libraries you want to use without having
to worry so much about all this stuff in
the libraries that you don't need and
how it might load your app size in this
case we're using the support library
before and v7 and notifications and
design and all kinds of assets and we're
only using a subset of the support
libraries so everything we're not using
just gets torn away at Build time and
eliminated now you might tell you might
be thinking this is nice it's a nice
benefit but the optimizations make
debugging more difficult so hold that
thought until the next demo what we've
done for code we can do for resources as
well same principle here resource
shrinking extends the concept of pro
guards dead code elimination to
resources so in this example drawables
whose references are reachable from live
code are kept in your apk and then
everything else is deleted now our app
is almost 4x smaller
and this is no mistake all we've done is
tweak two lines of Gradle but what we
get is once again things that are that
going to sort of the transitive closure
of dependencies of our app but are not
actually useful to the app once a so
once again this is due to features
included in our dependencies that we
don't need the support libraries in this
case contain a lot of design assets that
you could use but Topeka isn't so we can
just make all the dead weight go away
but we can do even better so if you
recall we saw that in the resource
folder with the when we were looking
with the apk analyzer we have drawables
for different screen densities what's
going on the Android ecosystem is
diverse with support for different
displays and different cpu types and
other such things by default when you
build an apk with all the material to
service as many devices as possible we
call that the universal apk you get a
larger apk than what's actually needed
on each particular device every specific
device that runs your app will only use
files for its particular density and if
you have native code then for its
particular CPU architecture and other
such things that apk can vary on
fortunately you can split your build
across these dimensions right and then
upload multiple apks to play each one
tailored to a particular device type
here we intentionally look at the apk
built for xxhdpi density screens which
contains the largest PNG s because this
is the largest apk that we were building
for this app in this example you will
see that the difference is significant
even when comparing the universal apk to
the largest split that we have and of
course the difference is more pronounced
for hdpi and dpi etc speaking of PNG s
and densities we can do even better with
vector drawables telling us thanks i so
now we just saw that there's a way to
deliver a smaller app by chunking it up
and delivering multiple of those apps
now that's a great benefit to apk size
but it does come at a cost for your
build process as well as your your QA
process and that might be something that
you're not quite ready to to get into so
now there's an additional approach you
can follow to reduce the
of size you carry with your assets and
that's use vector drawables vector
drawables would basically serving a
vector into your application so there's
a single asset that can serve up all of
the densities for this particular asset
on screen the vector drawable is
actually smaller than the smallest
density PNG so it's it's quite nice and
this is I would consider it to be kind
of a medium complexity vector with
somewhat complex paths and but not
necessarily gradients and things like
that the thing that makes I think vector
drawable very usable and exciting today
is that in support library 23 2 we
introduced support for vector drawables
backwards compatible all the way to API
14 also in with n we introduced gradient
support a vector drawable so hopefully
that gives you kind of a wider range of
things you can do you can do with
vectors now one thing to keep in mind
with vectors is that they can increase
your your RAM and CPU load especially
when you first start up the application
so if you have an app that is sorry a
series of assets that are pre complex
then you probably want to do kind of bit
of a performance test and make sure that
you're not sacrificing a lot of
performance in exchange for for a
smaller app size now let's go ahead and
savings after substituting most of the
PNG s with vector assets which this app
is very good at because it's all flat
images with relatively low complexity we
see that vector drawables is a little
bit better than multi apk that kind of
makes sense right because we're carrying
just a single asset in the application
our advice would be that you consider
what kind of image assets are in your
application so if they are relatively
simple and flat you should definitely
consider it
and then that also simplifies your your
building QA process so that you only
have to produce one apk to upload to
play so let me hand it back to Shai for
one more best practice awesome thanks so
finally we're going to see a specialized
trick for resources a or C that's too
because air-sea file so to pick up their
C file as we saw is small but we'll make
it 2 X smaller with one line because we
can
so here you can look inside the Eric C
file and view all the strings
translation and also here live on stage
now you'll notice that some strings only
appear in English for instance there's
there's going to be sign in here and
sign out but other strings have as many
as eighty two translations for them why
is this happening so the support library
folks went out of their way to localize
your strings and kudos to them because
this is the right thing for a library to
do a lot of Alps go to similar lengths
to translate their own strings and you
want the libraries to kind of line up so
that the app is in-house translated
right not the case with Topeka it didn't
bother with anything but English which
is typical of our sample apps
translating your app is a good way to
reach out to more users and we
absolutely encourage that we Google
translates all of its apps to as many
languages as this but I have translated
out can make a poor user experience and
then what's worse is these empty spaces
actually use a byte in our air C file by
indicating sort of null entries across
eighty-two locales for all the strings
that weren't translated so what are we
going to do we're going to get rid of
them and we can fix all this by simply
stating that we only want to retain
English strings and then all the half
translations just disappear right out so
I know this is hard to see the
difference but if you look under your
seats you will find a pair of binoculars
each made you look I promised air C is
now 2 X molar although in the big
pictures this doesn't do much since we
small to begin with on the other hand
I've seen real apps that are 40% arsc
true story so once again your mileage
may vary now let's take a look back and
appreciate the fact that our Topeka app
is now 5 X smaller than when we started
over 5x in fact it's not even 10 a.m.
thank you thank you thank you what I've
shown you so far is all existing
functionality now I'll hand it over to
Klara to tell us about yourself
thank you say new stuff Klara
hi I'm Clara Valerie I'm a tech lead on
the Android UI toolkit team and I work
on fonts so here I'm very excited to
introduce today we're presenting
downloadable fonts fonts are a source of
bloat for apps and we know that they're
heavy files they're stuck into your app
and you need them because you need it
for your UX that's fine we figured out
that actually most fonts that you are
bundling in your apps are not even
optimized for mobile so about half of
the apk have that file size that you're
adding is not even something we're going
to use in Android so that's a shame
also we looked at the Play Store and we
figured out that the 25 apps that bundle
fonts are actually bundling about an
average of 500 kilobytes in fonts that
we own in the Google Fonts catalog like
okay we should be able to do something
with that right never mind the fact that
several apps are bundling the same fonts
and you're duplicating them in your
device so that's where downloadable
fonts comes in you've typically bundled
fonts in your app and that causes your
apk size to increase with downloadable
fonts we're introducing the concept of a
fonts provider there you can we go back
please
there you cons provider is a separate
app that is not yours that is its own
mission is to fetch fonts for you cash
them and serve them to you when you need
them
this means that you can stop bundling
fonts in your app and Trust the font
provider to do it for you the way this
works is all apps can just contact the
cloud provider via the fonts contract
api's these are available in Android L
and in support library 26 beta 1 by
doing this all of the apps are
contacting the same thought provider
which means we have one copy of the font
that all apps are using at the same time
what does this mean really well it means
we save memory because we're only
loading the font once and sharing that
memory between all apps we're also
saving apk size for all of these apps
because they don't have to bundle the
font and they're just we just have one
copy
we're obviously saving this space for
the user because
all of your apps are smaller and we're
also saving Network if you are actually
fetching fonts from the network as only
the font provider is the one responsible
for fetching these this is available in
support library today and I'm very proud
to announce our very first font provider
which is available it's a great
collaboration was done with the Google
Fonts team where we're providing the
entire google fonts catalog and that is
800 fonts available to your app to use
free from apk size isn't that amazing
that is done through Google Play
services it has a tiny caveat this is in
Google Play services v11 which is
currently in beta next I want to hand it
over to Wojtek to give you a very smooth
demo of how under Studio have integrated
with downloadable fonts thank you
[Applause]
so hi everyone my name is Wojtek I'm a
developer advocate working closely in
the Android studio team and today I want
to walk you through some of the new
features we have an Android studio and
tools that are relevant to apk size and
hopefully will keep your apk size down
so it's Clara explained a lot of
downloadable fonts are a great way to
make your apps look pretty without
adding the blow to your apk so let me
show you how easy we can add
downloadable songs to your app in
Android studio so here I have open one
of the layouts files from the Topeka app
and you can see if I click on the text
view here on the right and the layout
inspector I can actually go and change
the font so I scroll down and if I
select more fun there's this new picker
in Android studio 3.0 that we just
announced yesterday and you can see here
you have access to literally hundreds of
fonts from the google fonts catalog and
if I if I just choose one here I can
select the downloadable font I can see
the file immediately change in the
preview but then what's more Android
studio also includes support for binary
and XML fonts projects folder structure
and see your preview or edit it so
that's one thing but where we when we're
on the topic of resources we are also
making changes to a apt which is the
Android assets packaging tool this is
the part of the build system that
processes and packages all your
resources into the ATK and with Android
studio 3.0 we are introducing a new
version of a apt apt 2 which has a few
neat tricks for reducing your apk size
so first up we have as something we call
version collapsing so normally when you
develop an app you add resources for
various versions of Android typically
you want to have different colors of
different styles for the different
versions of the platform and that also
happens for example in the support
library which you normally bring into
your apps but as you develop your app
and time passes you normally start
raising your min SDK version and kind of
restricting the versions of Android that
your apps run on and but these resources
still remain especially if they come
from external dependencies
so they take up unnecessary space in
your apk so with a apt - we are
introducing version collapsing we're 80
think you can actually figure out the
min SDK of your app and get rid of all
these resources that are unneeded and
what's more and can collapse the
configurations in your app to reduce the
size of the resources file even further
only including the resources that your
app actually will need next up we have
resource video application so another
example here I'm showing different
translations for your app and it happens
sometimes that in some for some
languages for some configurations like
here French and French Canadian mostly
the translations will be the same most
of the words are exactly the same except
for just a few and it doesn't make sense
to actually keep these duplicate
resources and in the resources file
so what apt - will do now it will find
those duplicate resources get rid of
them and let the system default to the
to the default configuration so this is
a version collapsing and resource
deduplication apq - does a couple of
more internal things like it starts
using utf-8 for text for string
resources included in xml files like
layouts and the binary resources file it
has a smart air cruncher this is the
part that reduces the size of your
images by optimizing them and if it
finds that your images are actually
already pre optimized and the output of
apt - crunching would be bigger then it
just discards there's bigger versions
and uses smaller ones so we aim to
enable apt - as the default in Android
studio 3 Toto stable however you can try
it now with the cannery 1 release all
you have to do is add this one line to
your Gradle properties file so I
encourage you to try it and reduce the
size of your educate without doing
anything so like I said you don't have
to say change a single line of code when
you use apt - but sometimes that's not
enough sometimes you actually want to go
in and in fact and and change things in
your app and any tools to help you make
decisions of where to actually go and
make this up
so likes to the lick shy mentioned
before one of the biggest changes you
can make to your app to this apk size is
a needle ProGuard to shrink away
Cauldron resources but when talking to
developers at conferences like this I
often hear that it's very difficult to
debug build problems and runtime
problems that can stem from an evening
program in your apps and developers were
really lacking tools that will let them
inspect those problems in detail that's
why we're making some improvements to
the apk analyzer in Android studio let
me show you an example can we switch to
the demo please so here I have Android
studio 300 can everyone running on my
machine and well one of the first things
sorry I'm gonna walk you through a few
things that we're adding to let you
better debug program programs but we've
also added some UI tweaks to the API
analyzer that hopefully will make it I'm
working with it even easier so the first
thing you might notice is we now have
multi decks support so I can select
multiple decks files and actually see a
combined preview of all the code in my
app so this is a very simple example
this is not just a peek app this is just
an IPA I created for the purpose of this
demo and and you can see I can drill
down to the source code of my app here
and actually see all the other classes
that I have and the app really has two
parts it's very simple it just has an
activity and it has the fragment the
thing is the fragment the way I use it
is I only use it from a layout XML file
and that will be important later we also
made some other tweaks to the decks
viewer so for example we have some
filtering options and I can for example
disable showing
classes there are reference from my file
but are not actually defined in it but
moving onto ProGuard so this is a debug
build this has for this progress is not
enabled so I built my release apk I run
it and the first big problem with the
app is it crashes the crashes on startup
I don't know why it solves the class not
found exception and the second problem
is if I actually go and try to debug the
problem
I can see again like shy mentioned that
all the names of my types of my fields
methods they were all changed to drink
like ABC it's very difficult to debug
the problem here so what I can do now
with the new Android studio is I can
actually load the ProGuard mappings that
were created with them when my ATK was
built so let me open the program mapping
folder here and now you can see the text
viewer changed first I can actually see
all the names of classes packages
everything's back like it was in my
original source code second I can
actually go here and see now that my
blank fragment is missing that's because
ProGuard was not able to automatically
detect the text that is being used in my
code what's more I can press this button
here which will let me show all the
removed nodes that were removed by
ProGuard yep so I found the black
fragment here it was removed i right to
it right-click on it and I can actually
generate a pro gradual that I can
that I can simply copy and paste to my
program configuration so I'm going to
I'm going to choose the first rule it's
the simplest one I just want to keep the
class and all its members so I copy it
here I rebuild my app and I open the apk
after after rebuilding it I've loaded
the program mappings so that we can keep
things brief brief I open it and what's
more I can see that the black fragment
is not only here it's shown in bold
which means it was explicitly kept by
the program configuration so that's
that's the program support and Android
studio and I think analyzer but there's
more for real power users you can
actually now go and and figure out how
how the classes that you use and the
dependencies that you have pull even
more code inside your app so for example
I know that in my source code I'm using
this class called optional but I've
never used this one or this one so why
is it here I can now right-click on any
class or method and actually find usages
and get a nice tree of dependencies and
see that actually this present class is
used by this method from the optional
which I'm using from mine on my own
create what's more I can actually verify
that by opening my on create method and
looking at the exact bike write code of
that method now I know not every one of
you will need to use this but if you
work with like very complicated build
system as we do your own biko
transformations now you can actually
analyze the byte code that gets packaged
in your apk ok can we switch back to
slide please so this is available in
Android studio now however there are
some more things that we're working on
and hopefully you'll get to play with
them in the future but now let me give
you a sneak peek so in the Dex your
previously we had only two columns
showing the number of defined methods
and reference methods which is useful if
you're debugging problems with multi
decks not really problems mold exacts
but problems with the amount of the
number of methods we are adding a third
column that will show you the actual
byte size per package class and
method so you can see how the
functionality you add to your code or
the libraries that you pull into your
codebase impact the deck size and apk
size of your app and the last thing is I
showed you how you can compare to ATK's
but so far the functionality was quite
limited and only worked on the raw apk
size we are expanding the compare 80k
action to actually get to give you the
actual update size as delivered by the
Play Store from one version of your app
to the other and we even include the new
file-by-file support that's been added
to play and if you're not familiar with
file-by-file patches let me invite on
stage james from the play team who can
explain it better hi everyone my name is
James I'm a product manager on the
Google Play Store Play delivers a lot of
apps in the last year we delivered 82
billion app installs and even more
patches to keep those apps up to date we
saw earlier in the presentation how app
size directly correlates with install
success so users couldn't be givers
giving us a more clear signal that they
care about the size of these downloads
so in the last year play invested a lot
in taking significant steps to reduce
apk size for downloads and updates I'm
delighted to say that we had some great
success and I'd like to tell you about
two of those in particular the first was
broadly compression now at Google
we're always super proud of our interns
but this one's going to take some
beating our intern Anna to broadly which
is a new compression format from the
Google research Europe team and applied
it to the pet to the Play Store that one
change reduced our data usage by 1.5
petabytes a day compared to our previous
method of using gzip for everything this
is crazy right we're super pleased with
these results and you can be sure we
made Anna an offer to join us fill time
secondly when Google Play updates an app
as the guy said previously we deliver
patches so we started out by just
delivering the full apk for each update
and then we switch to using diffing
algorithms to generate deltas between
all the apks and new apks now there's an
issue with this as we know apk is our
zip archives that are compressed so take
a look at this blob of text on the next
slide I changed one character did you
see it it's in the top left second words
can we go back a slide and then we see
it again okay
got it now let's look at the gzip -6
compressed version of that here's the
first blob of text and here's the second
blob of text and remember we only change
one character so let's see that again
it's pretty crazy so a compressed
version produces a massively different
blob of compressed text that means the
patch between the two is very
inefficient so we decide to get smarter
about how we generate patches we launch
the new system called file by file
patching we decided to uncompress the
apks and generate the deltas on the
uncompressed versions every single file
file by file this creates a far more
efficient patch and then we reverse the
process when we apply the patch on the
device
the result we saved six petabytes of
user data per day on average patches are
no 65 percent smaller than the original
app size and some are even smaller
Netflix's original app is 16 megabytes
but the patch size was only one megabyte
and 92% saving so with these two changes
we've dropped our data usage by 7.5
petabytes per day to give put that in
context that's roughly equivalent to a
hundred years of HDTV video every single
day
if that doesn't give you an idea of the
scale of Android and play so next we're
going to take a different route we're
introducing Google Play app signing if
you join this program Google Play will
manage your key on your behalf and sign
your app before delivering it to users
now
once Google Play signed your app we can
go one step further and we can provide
app size optimizations now you heard
earlier about multi apk and the stuff
that's not required on each device if I
have a 32-bit architecture and a hate
CPI screen then I only need the contents
of the boxes in blue and the rest of the
apk is completely unnecessary from my
device with app optimizations we deliver
just the right content for each device
so if multi apk is too difficult too
complicated or you're doing it just now
and you don't want to anymore
sign up for our optimization and you
know it never need to again you you give
us a universal apk and we will
automatically create an optimized apk
for different devices on screen density
and native architecture now we're just
getting started
exploring this area it's really early
but we've tried this out with a few apps
that were in our early access program
for app signing and we expect the
average savings to be about 15% however
some apps see even better results the
Libero was 33% smaller after the
optimizations and this 7 minute workout
app with nearly a hat smaller so we're
really excited about this we think this
is going to be a huge benefit to users
and developers so how can you get these
benefits
well app signing is available today you
can go out and get enrolled straightaway
we are trying app optimizations in beta
with a few select partners at the moment
and we hope to widen the beta in the
near future
if you are interested in optimizations
please enroll in app signing and if
you'd like to find out more about these
two please come to our talk at 2:30 p.m.
today at this on stage one next door so
thank you very much for listening today
we've covered a lot of the best
practices that you can do to slim down
your apk size it's really important to
users so I really hope that you take
something away from this and go and
invest in making this better if you'd
like to find out more you can talk to
the Android and play teams in sandbox
dorm C thanks again
[Applause]
[Music]